[Musique]
pour recevoir les enfants
bon
alors nounours tu nous lis pas l'être
non entre na mois au moins tu es bien
mystérieux nous jeter sans la lire chez
nicolas et pimprenelle
on l'échelle
hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
lundi les enfants bonsoir
vous permettez une lettre urgente
voyons vous ou nous qu'est ce que ça
veut dire voyons nicolas
monsieur nounours
ou yushu roudou
roug'chou
mariou kourou où c'est mon cousin ils se
marient ils m'invitent à son mariage
liu
comment vais je m'habille et je n'ai
rien à me trotter fait pas on a tout ce
qu'il faut ça dans ma chambre je
t'apporte des vêtements
en bon ordre madame
voilà un beau mariage de papa tient à
chaque fois pour notre nounours
l'a1 à papillons de mariage tiens et
abus des papillons pour notre nouveau ou
finir une jolie paire de dans leurs
frais tiens et hervé van der fait qu'on
entraîne une hausse diane montrait amour
j go
faut que je suis un
sacré en loup le loup nous connaissons
les enfants voyagent bien fait un must
toi bien soyez tranquille
on peut tout
[Musique]
tout était clean
j'ai bien l'impression que nous partons
en voyage mais nous reviendrons vue de
vous voir et nous vous raconterons de
belles histoires à bientôt
à bientôt
fait de pour eux
[Musique]